for me it has to be the sass for me
there's a constant sort of flood of
ideas and perceptions and you're not
writing a poem until you manage to slow
the flood down or shape it a little bit
by sinking a bad what's flood backwards
duffel what is it inside out fold so you
unfold whatever's been crammed into the
duffel bag of your consciousness bla bla
bla bla so it's like noodling at a piano
or smooshing paint around or I suppose a
carver whittling or just getting the
clay and the table thinking about how
you what it'll do in response to the
different shapes that you make your
hands into so it starts very much with
the physical sense of the language
though you hope and starts as a kind of
a very short easy way to say you hope
something that started in an emotion
something in your heart or some thought
you've had you didn't know it was
starting a poem you don't feel like
you're making a work of art until you
have the physical materials there so
someone's painting or someone's uh jazz
chorus or an actress performance starts
with the position of the body or a
particular circumstance or particular
tune that's when the work of art starts
but the emotion the ideas may have
started when you were three years old
you're right with you you're right with
your breath that your year so if we go
back in the Sony duffel bag palm you
fiddle with it you fiddle with it and
you think why should fiddle me in a word
that's just something aimless who first
said about Nero that he fiddled while
Rome burned
is there any just does that have any
historical reality and those other
double f-words affable ineffable and
then you go back to what you actually
want to talk about and it turns out to
be you know yes yourself why does any of
this matter and you say well there's
something about work and fiddling sounds
like it's not serious work is roofing
serious work it's said to be the most
brutal of all the trades it's dangerous
you're always very hot or very cold the
materials themselves compared to wood
that you're framing with they're plaster
when you're dry walls are kind of
obdurate and ugly and in a way it's a
symbol of civilization oh it's a
civilization duffl the roofer was civil
when he asked me if we could use the
bathroom I tried to be deaf yeah so
you're thinking vaguely about work and
you're thinking vaguely about this
befuddling set of consonants and vowels
and you're hoping that between work
roofing fiddling you might say a
sentence or a line that actually sounds
meaningful and you
you run your you run your hand over it
if your sandpapering and you play it in
tempo with the chords in your hand left
hand putting the bass and you trace the
harmony it's physical so you say the
poem aloud sometimes you try to what say
it to yourself when the light is out and
you're ready to go to sleep and it could
come to a part you can't do you turn the
light on and ask yourself is that a part
I could make better so it's you try it
out just like if you made an airplane